продовжимо а наші брифінгу
easy станом готовності наших початкових
заплатити цього почали робаро вас
дізнається мінні зі свитою наук та магії
спорт від метро vall додому штабу шини
качка інформація дали вашого харчування
добрий далі ми вникали не просто над
області системного світла даного
початкову руку його районів ділянці
засідання прем'єр-міністра до реле напруження
я починаю їжі гола дозволивши б сергію
точно цю інформацію якуну давав
прем'єр-міністр 4 з порожніми мільйонами та
дружників
для учень великих класі видру кого не
наслідував його за блискавку і
до 15-го сотня дістав і не будинок усіх шкіл
прем'єр-міністр уже сказав усе було
капітально відрі mantova на із бутово на
дві з половиною тисячі домішок
завального світла їх початкових закладі
взагалі 17000 домішок скілл за знав і за
знав і поточного ремонту і виборі тип
rapid ручник та цинічний рекордний rig 4
з половиною мільйон і для великого
класу до 15 товар з не
це 15-го ступеня доставлено дашкін до
20 іншого серпня може вам мільйони
підручнику
для до 12 класів та хоч їх без повернуть
його ще повністю за блискавка всіх шкіл
виконана в
реальному у світі ту хто так як вид
буваєте
якусь нову
навчання крем того трендово хотів би
сказати ще одні у нас продовжите
високий темп і підготовки та розвинений
кудашкіна і осип екш його в 2009 уроки у
адже нас 53 сотки дітей з 3 до 6 року в
був ліха плані душ пильную святу і 61
особа так на початку працюєте Юрій
дубцова ведуть за заданий мікдар штату
у нас 2 77 сотки дітей з 3 до 6
руки в моїх можна вести вигляд винні
дужки у неї установок ікса говорить і про
hal blaine пушкіним святу 4 чік то
цифра
вигляд побачить на екрані європейським
стандартам 99 виси нам церква
сотка а в 20 регіонах забезпечена ставить
сотки в містику Дашкін їх установок для
об'єкти річок і щоб ці проживання його
них близько 970 7-ми сотки вінтажної
поганої допомоги євросоюз рекомендується
крейном 2 Європи
адже соток вид 80 до 85 і нам удалося з
берести
іпі дату від ярма north нову початкову
руку і зі своїм у бульбашки мною та усвяти
вона ж дружки приросла зубці і риф
на 5 установка разів 1500 установка
бульбашки та й освітлюватися центрі дитини
чого та творчості естетичної художник
юних натуралістів і такі ніші уявні
такої проблеми інші зростання та
про спершу світлі як наївність вакансії в
школах
школи повністю укомплектовані та
найголовніше відчутно роті спитаю кларис
не підкоряється
за ті нові державні стандарти всі
владно колючий елс нову модернізацію
святі з нової reforms in вважати б
можете всі організації не заходи
старіння матеріальні основи косметика
чому революції нести нові витриманих
стандарті я київську зима комісія
радою Європи назвала лінгвістичну
революції ротом ще старший мері сніг
сидить і пошту дівчата з пошиття класи
називаємо розумом і для тіла
сторони необхідно витий і в 4-е зарубати
на плато там де
у 4 пальчикових класів може тут не
ось і самі підготував і не запрягали з
ним на прям до мене які в університетах
початкова школа іноземному від анди не
будуть виходити в 4
зги наземні мови cph інший за новим
стандартом у навчанні ниркові інформатики
колір і пара замислювала класу панно
вкрай she's девіду мети побачи, а ви
іклам години
третина всієї школи України
старшого валі сне доступну руку чому
з п'ятого класу виїмчасте інше на
взаємному у клімату мами в Польщі
канали ви могли закону і тепер у нас у
всіх школах у всіх класів будуть три
модельною фізичною культурою клінтон
на тильній кліматі вал новий державний
стандарти шкіру імаго ще в ремонті школі
схожу по четвертий клас на будні кому
уроки року 2 фізичної паузи дві такі
місто купа стилі розминки уроки всієї
почерку в школі відповідь але будинок і
особистих рекомендацій старшому другу
класі будуть 40 хвали та плату можна
говорить і протягнув сума туди блювання
програми так менше я думаю щити тримаючи
поза стандартами он і адже побачить сам
кримінальному по Польщі попередній яскравістю
світили докладно ванни побуду ваней на
здоров'язберігаючих технологій екшену
горить і про матеріальну базу світить
принципі wanna love
а ще раз дозволю собі сказати про
практику сулія наваляв і для нас дуже
важливо тему
яка так уже говорилося на розширеному
засідання ряду
знаєте була багата скептики вказав шукають
христової по хіт затримки і не зупинить
там але кольори допомагати їх чорному pr
акція так от хочу сказати ще за годину
працює всі муриди в корі не стала на
годин п'ятдесят дошкільних заході в
найпростіших кожусі датчик садочку вище та
вище в першому упи в мові 2002 на тест
уроку за новою на свою роботу 199
дошкільних заклань
ще за голом дало 171 з половиною тисяч
міс дати а чикса дочках менше за них було
по передній обожню частіше позбавляються ми
цеповяза нас ти ще 3 рік після літає
вже надійшов на графічну тенденцію з
шкірним рукам зважується гель кисть
дітей все морозі у старший клас живити
він від 430 тисяч дітей спочатку cbd
тут на варті з гілок думаючий
porsche та горе знято не знається не
просто зонально державність зв'язатися з
сімейний світловий цінне національного
примирення у webmoney вона біля школи
знань про святих там уже битий усієї
матюки заклав великий політичних
пам'ятають його не сядуть пір або запаркований
їх водневого вчителя до
і 1 улюблена деревця ще любимо ваші
володареві візової тієї битви істина ваша
застава шас про ітан і україна натаска
безмовно
робота над проектом бюджету проходить на
пружинному і подалася своєю позицією в
міністерство фінансів і хотіла бути
більше ти ну та й кінопремій фінансово
не зі свити ланцюг далі чого припинення
соціального статусу первинних
противників припинення заробітної плати
у 4 алкоголічка противником поклону ніж
вище початкових заході працювати з
берести та трофі примножить і програму
комп'ютеризації розвитку you та к-т
технології в середній школі ти ще
називається програма тримав наставити
добу я колись кликав і не просто вже
підключіть усі нормальні зарплати до
інтернету і ж друкував новий
матеріальні бази 3 навіть важливі його
програма з вивчай на шкільний автобус
мис подіємо з нас тут на морозі та
просто завершіть проста kotaku проблему
зайняті прямий доступ вона називається дай
окисне світло на звучали напій риму
такі програми я київському було за
чітко вольниці йому не дам я моєї ланки
у чані на і без того на вигляд їхньому студенту
аспірантуру краще зарубіжних
університетах знаєте я не кличу bon на
людей нуал і
перед ти нікого не пройшли апробацію в
мінфіні та готова їх побачити закону дав
все думаючими в цифрах праворуч праворуч
динаміці ігор стане частиною чиєїсь не
любиш література прийняла потрібно лише і
прогнав літератури і як же їх
вони разом добрі до мастила в Україні
українська форматі його водіння чеки
хвилин за якусь такого молодого та на
20000 кен
я в міністерство задратися куб, а ось
ці книжки і за тульською і провал ще
програм важливими та зарубіжною
літератури а програма дуже гарно з
українській літературі також вона
дієва розван теж сечому там ще
поляна ельза віддаленої у тому ще де ти
за річкою навчали 60 біографії зарубіжних
chevy chase даних листи ніки праворуч
все плані
внутрішні вимагають врахування щодо
на повну нешкільну бібліотеку ми
вперше всім уроки вкотре спочив і вже за 1
друг
абсолютно унікальні серії шкільна
бібліотека розруха ванної на 13000 пилок
близького 6 досягне це вмію у рішенні
з розкиною краще
святої та української та зарубіжної та
російської літератури клінтоном та
будинковими сприяючи сійській федерації
ванній торі обійдуть передають вже за раз
на тисячі бібліотек по 20 цей
міф з бирку російської класах та блиску
що без custom середньому школам доббі блеф
ти їх усіх з Еньші і в ряд також
скластися на такі гуманні кола
будемо а так йому зовнішній ок і
міністерство свиті уряду російському
федерації щодо там скажімо а таких
дискусій навколо програма я просто
хотів би повернути якщо ось висловив ще
на річчю там скажемо а включені обидва ви
ключові хмари і блазан ведмедика ними особливо з
так у леді так ось я хотів би сказати
ще наприклад
гаррі поттер включені в програму
після класного чогось не я
2004 руси але не маячити б наші особливі
століттях а не я у нас за цими за собою
масової інформації він і прокидаються
бачу тріщин змінилося а в одинадцятому
уроки з ременя на четвертому передати
піддаються витягуєте
100 салонів не страшних та мобільний
великих тиражів трибуни, що думають, чистий і
не в 4к листівки бібліотека візуально
доступну та інтернет ресурсам і чому там
ще тримаючи на програму на більше не йшли
за зростання рубаємо у поки що на розрив його
на ми хочемо оку комплекту вати шпиль не
бібліотеки ними книжкам який ця вивіска
в січні ти в не чистий і не топ той ще
до нього варіативного ряд його цінував
Барскова В.М. з кору гуд будемо
укомплектувати та взуття school
а там де з твій учасник 3 4 ти в
бібліотеку тим більше рахунків то реле
температури такі великі вночі було
варіація розуміючих скажімо вона шкіряний
клас початковий нарик рекомендованого
біт pewter і пхати не до 200 мг
відразу мило все на гарячі вкладки
на літературному грудку папанова ти там
уфа kitty я повинен формат університету в
коли яєчних була закладена дробово над
загальним у 4 мих мих
мехман і вру лати старіли звуки до десятки
хмарі це 100 нас вибрати цю yahoo і в
бібліотеці
надходив вас поділася будемо поповнять і
бібліотеки сказати з'явитися в китаї jet
на шістку хом'ячки нами загальмувала
деталі ходить чим арк біля вести центр
оремо точними крихітне доступно нас до
якою я закінчу розкладачки ну раз
бачив і так важливо все закон та багато ще
один знижка це закінчиться нікому не
може 7 тиша буде на шляху відразу цього
наказу мо дії однак ми катаємось
право обласна друкувати інший предмет
школи не мовчать і цуканів при подує
через дачу в тонус і нещодавно побажаю
просто борщ тканини травня ніж докази і
відьму цю ось до приймання школи владними
сама система харчування ваз говорять на
тренажер знав навіть у столицях 3
починаючи з 20 руку гурієм облік йому я
можу вам сказати ще бачили не дитя чого
садко ago 0 класу на її вивіску ніхто
не може і не коване відро для їжі ти
не